I took my working took one two three
four five six lines six lines so if it
was much longer than that I wonder if
you're taking a rather indirect path to
what it there's lots of different ways
to do this but i'll show you my if
anyone's got an improvement on line on
my friend to hear have a look at part 1
part 1 that was where we solved for T 1
and this is the result they asked for
we're doing exactly the same thing but
just 42 okay so how do I start this
question well I looked and I saw and I
thought what makes T one's special what
is the characteristic about that time
which I can take advantage of and the
answer was the X and the y coordinates
are the same at that time okay well time
to is special in a similar way it just
has different conditions the different
quality that makes it time to when T
equals t2 okay what's special about it
will probably the most obvious thing is
that being that it hits the ground again
its vertical displacement is 0 right
sonoma county's that make sense so i'm
going to use that just like i use this
as my starting point okay i have an
equation for vertical displacement it's
this guy right so i'm going to go from
there let's see I'm going to have minus
GT 2 squared hmm lots of subscripts and
superscripts plus u T 2 sine theta they
go alpha sorry that's zero here's my
vertical displacement okay and it's hit
the ground there it is now what am I
going to do here a couple of different
things i want to make tea to the subject
don't I just like I made team won the
subject again just like before I see a
common factor common factor t2 and i can
divide through just like i divided
through here cuz t2 is non zero right so
I'm gonna do that I'm gonna get this
Plus this and I'm going to say why
that's a terrible brace sorry I'm gonna
say why i can divide through by teaching
i must justify that that's important
okay now what was I supposed to do a
space to solve for t2 wasn't it okay so
let's rearrange this
kick this u sine theta over the other so
you say alpha keeps a better over to the
other side divide through by everything
and you end up with this oh my god um to
you on gee sine alpha got it right that
time okay now how's that look it's
simple but it's not what i was expecting
right so what am i going to do with this
how am I going to get there's no t1 at
all in this equation and there's no card
either how can I introduce it okay well
have a look at t2 it makes my you're
quite n four digit and have a look at
mighty one they bear a striking
similarity do they're not you've got
your to you want G up the front which is
the same you have to sign up which is
the same piece right so what's the most
direct part in here to here as a couple
of ways to do this but the simplest way
is to take advantage of the fact that
you know exactly what should be equal to
you know exactly what it should be equal
to okay so even though it seems like a
bit of a stab in the dark I'm going to
do this x 1 minus chi alpha on 1 minus
alpha now if you didn't know what the
result was ahead of time this is a very
unlikely course of action why would you
do this ok but you and I can see where
it's going to go I have to have a 1
minus cot alpha on the denominator
eventually so I might as well put it
there now and if i have it on the
denominator well you can't just multiply
by things / things i should have it on
the top as well ah you can see it's
going to happen cut you this thing here
when i multiply by the numerator right
your to you on g is out the front sine
alpha x 1 sorry that's a gee sine alpha
types cot alpha that's closed on side x
side that's that's cause there you go
just as you expected okay see it and
there's your tea one on the numerator
cool that's it use given results as much
as possible right whenever you're headed
somewhere keep one eye on your working
and one eye on your destination
because that'll take you the fastest
puff